So we're gonna do a new topic today.
We're going to talk about evolution.
We're going to run the connection
between evolution and game theory.
All right, now that is going
to be a, uh, an extra rank.
I already emailed you about this.
There's going to be an extra reading on
this with the people who want it. Uh,
I'm gonna,
uh,
th there's a reading packet that's
available to anybody who wants it.
I emailed you all the websites where you
can order that weeding packet and find
and figure out where to pick it up.
It's not compulsory,
you don't have to look at that reading
packet. It's just, it might help.
In addition, as with last Wednesday,
since some of the material here is new,
I have written a handout that goes
with this lecture and that handout will
appear magically this afternoon
on the website. All right,
so you have to do things today are fast.
Don't worry.
There's a handout that goes
with it. All right, so why,
why look at evolution in
the context of Game Theory?
There are really two reasons.
The first reason is
because of the influence
of game theory on biology.
It turns out that in the last few decades,
there's been an enormous amount of work,
dom in biology in particular.